proche de Pierre palan en tout cas
bouscule pas pour aller le voir mais
forcément c'est compliqué puisqu'ils
n'ont pas le droit visite claire la
seule sœur avec qui il était en contact
et qui gérait ses affaires aurait claqué
la porte de l'hôpital deux jours après
l'accident le 12 février dernier
lorsqu'elle a entendu son frère Pierre
prononcé une phrase que vous dévoilez
donc Paris Match ce qui montre son sa
totale inconsciente alors justement deux
jours après cette phrase série qui est
incroyable dis donc elle va valoir cher
ma première interview ce qui montre ça
total inconscience de que voilà encore
une fois on sait que le 11 12 février il
comprend pas enfin c'est il se
positionne au tout départ comme une
victime il est victime de la drogue ce
qui lui arrive c'est très dur et donc il
met du temps
et ce sera la phrase ce sera le cas en
fait ça voudra faire cette première
interview parce que c'est unique et ce
sera comme ça malheureusement
ou alors il comprend que peut-être le
silence est la meilleure des choses
faudra faire la première interview de
Pierre Palmade peut-être oui mais en
tout cas il y a des vrais révélations
c'est incroyable sa mère qui réside à
Bordeaux n'a pas pris le train pour
venir rendre à ville sa mère est
totalement absente de cette affaire
depuis le 10 février sa mère elle
pourrait venir le visitons la laisser
rentrer sa mère non techniquement oui la
famille sont les seules personnes a
priori qui compte plus la facilité
d'accès et pour l'instant ça va maman
elle n'est jamais vue elle était fâchée
depuis 2 ans d'accord tu étais fâché
depuis 2 ans oui mais peut-être c'est
une manière aussi de non pas de news en
tout cas elle a pas estimé utile de
prendre le train pour aller voir son
fils donc comme vous l'avez dit il dit
qu'il a été lâché par Muriel Robin et sa
femme Anne par Michel Laroque qui peut
encore compter c'est pas des vrais amis
sur Carole Bouquet
précisé que normalement les passions
restent deux semaines dans ce service
mais Pierre Palmade on est déjà sa
sixième semaine pourquoi faire Palmade
et il a fait 6 semaines alors que les
autres font deux semaines pour parce que
Pierre Palmade est sous contrôle
judiciaire un contrôle judiciaire très
strict qui a été établi entre la juge et
son avocate avec beaucoup de choses
qu'il ne peut pas faire d'accord et
notamment il doit rester dans une
structure médicalisée sous surveillance
médicale et donc il a été convenu que ce
protocole 1 durerait 6 semaines après
encore une fois on va voir ce qu'on fait
ensuite alors comme vous l'avez dit que
va-t-il se passer lundi on va vous dire
parce que lundi c'est une journée
importante après deux mois et demi passe
à l'hôpital il pourrait quitter
l'hôpital dès lundi prochain il devrait
donc avoir un nouveau contrôle
judiciaire c'est ça en attendant la date
fatidique de son procès son contrôle
judiciaire actuel ne lui permet pas de
retourner dans sa maison il interdiction
de quitter l'Île-de-France donc il
pourrait soit aller dans son appartement
dans le 3e arrondissement de Paris soit
aller chez l'une de ses sœurs qui
pourraient bien l'accueillir ou alors
aller dans un autre centre de soins type
voilà un centre de désintoxication un
autre hôpital qui serait prêt et à
l'hôpital et on attend en fait la
décision exactement mais il y a déjà un
hôpital qui a donné son nom on apprend
aussi et ça c'est les relations
incroyables que vous faites dans Paris
Match on apprend aussi que l'accident
était limite inévitable contenu de sa
récente descente aux enfers vous revenez
également vous donner là-dessus et
raconter que fin 2022 la situation était
déjà devenue très problématique fin 2022
le tournage de la fine équipe émission
commentaire palmat par France
Télévisions c'est sur France 2
vitrone naufrage sont cette capitaine du
bateau pierre arrive en Tarn ne
reconnaît pas ses invités sans faire
avec
ça souvent qui était son compagnon alors
avec son bout dans sa loge et son plus
sont plus déconnectés que jamais c'est
qui sont bons c'était son compagnon
malheureusement de sexe de soirée
glauque et c'était celui qui le piquait
mieux il l'avait dit d'ailleurs les
orteils
donc lui c'est lui qui le piqué il est
où ce ben s'il a été entendu par la
police et d'accord
dans une autre il avait interdiction de
le voir il était dans la voiture le jour
de l'accident alors donc oui donc on
apprend ça quoi donc il était raconté
donc en récidive parce qu'il avait pas
le droit de le voir effectivement mais
il est libre la promotion vous dites
tourne au fiasco lorsque après son
passage à l'antenne d'une station de
radio parisienne un sachet de cocaïne et
découvert dans les toilettes Palmade
empochera 170000 euros pour sa calamité
parce que il a plus de thunes il a
besoin d'argent parce que ça coûte très
cher d'avoir de ce fournir en trois MMC
et en coque et donc effectivement il a
peur que la promotion de l'émission
s'arrêtant qui ne touche pas le cachet
qui lui était promis c'était chez vous
Bernard Montiel ouais à la radio oui oui
j'ai lu le papier de match j'étais non
mais c'est chez vous c'était chez moi
vous savez qu'il y avait de la cocaïne
qui avait été retrouvé dans les
toilettes alors pour être honnête j'ai
reçu pierre pour le la fenêtit 2 c'est
ça et il était venu sur RFM répondre à
des questions il était pas très en forme
du tout à tel point que j'ai demandé à
ne pas diffuser les images n'ont pas été
diffusées parce qu'on enregistre
toujours nos interviews radio
effectivement et il était pas en forme
du tout bon il est parti on a réussi
quand même faire un goût d'entretien
plus ou moins intéressant et il se
trouve qu'en partant
une collègue est revenue en hurlant et
en Bernard ton pote il a laissé un petit
sachet dans les chiottes ça fait un
scandale énorme mais j'avoue que moi
moi-même j'en avais jamais parlé je sais
pas comment vous l'avez su mais en fait
c'est voilà ouais à toi tu le savais
alors non non non je sais qu'il prend
des trucs c'est pas toi qui a donné
l'info quoi ah non ça c'est pas ça
j'étais sidéré qu'il le sache parce que
justement je voulais j'ai même demandé à
mes collaboratifs de ne rien dire pour
parler donc c'est une info
d'ailleurs je l'ai lu je mange on a
parlé me suppression